diese steinformationen auf dem mars ist
wirklich ja ganz besonders kurios ist
sie etwa natürliche art oder endlich ein
beleg für leben auf dem mars der nase
rover curiosity hat ein foto vom roten
planeten geschickt das für aufregung
sorgt nicht nur im netz sondern auch in
der fachwelt und im laufe der jahre sind
noch viel mehr mysteriöse
gesteinsformationen auf dem mars
aufgetaucht weg zum science and future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
what the hell is going on hier was zur
hölle soll das sein so hat es der nasa
mitarbeiter kevin will formuliert seiner
meinung nach müssen es nun
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
erklären was hinter diesem kuriosen fund
auf dem mars steckt die rede ist von
einer wirklich kurios anmutenden
stammformation einen bogen aus stein
wenn man es genau nimmt und genau der
versetzt sowohl die fachwelt als auch
internet userinnen und user in großer
aufregung denn auf den ersten blick
scheint es überhaupt nicht so als sei
diese steinformationen natürlichen
ursprungs wer steckt hinter dieser
kuriosen anordnung oder anders gefragt
wie ist sie entstanden ist dass
möglicherweise ein beleg für leben auf
dem roten planeten und es gibt noch viel
mehr rätselhafte und spektakuläre
gesteinsformation auf dem mars alles
über die verblüffende geologie auf dem
mars und seltsame und kuriose funde
jetzt hier bei klicks um science and
future aufgespürt wurde der stein bogen
im geld krater auf dem roten planeten
der einen durchmesser von 160 kilometern
hat bereits im sommer entstanden ist die
sowohl durch einen meteoriteneinschlag
vor 3,5 milliarden jahren dieser hatte
einst dafür gesorgt dass sich das klima
auf dem roten planeten veränderte die
flüsse und seen in einem einst feucht
warmen klima verwandelten sich in eine
karge eisige wüstenlandschaft dazu der
us wissenschaftler william rappen im
geld krater ist der wandel des mars auf
einzigartige weise konserviert somit ist
jetzt also klar wie der rote planet vor
etwa dreieinhalb milliarden jahren
ausgesehen hat wasser war demnach ein
zentrales element auf dem planeten hat
sich in dieser zeit leben auf dem roten
planeten entwickelt dass möglicherweise
sogar noch heute existiert bereits seit
neun jahren ist der mars rover curiosity
im geld krater unterwegs hauptsächlich
auf der suche nach spuren von leben pro
stunde kann core city 30 meter
zurücklegen mit der hilfe seiner 17
kameras an bord und zehn
forschungsinstrumenten ist der perfekt
ausgestattet um wichtige daten zu
sammeln diese werden dann an die erde
gefunkt und ermöglichen es
forschungsteams rückschlüsse auf die
geschichte und bewohnbarkeit des roten
planeten zu ziehen jetzt also eine
aufnahme die selbst bei fachleuten für
verwunderung sorgt aufgespürt werden
konnte die seltsame stammformation in
einer übergangszone zwischen der sofort
haltigen und der leben haltigen region
des kraters beide gebiete haben
möglicherweise eine vergangenheit die
mit wasser zu tun hat die
nasa-wissenschaftler bgf raymond
beschreibt die nahaufnahme des stein
bogens als besonders wunderliches bild
einer interessanten stand ex tour sie
beschreibt sich selbst als verwundert
von der beschaffenheit die zu sehen ist
vor allem die beulen und klumpen die aus
dem grundgestein ragen seien besonders
spannend und faszinierend so die nasa
forscherin und auch ihr kollege kevin
gill von der nasa ist verwundert auf
täter rief er die fachwelt dazu auf
mögliche erklärung für diese kuriose
sichtung zu finden zitat ein live tap to
the sciences zu explain what the hell is
golden on her doch bevor sich andere
forschende überhaupt zu wort melden
konnten ja da meldet sie sich die
internetgemeinde es kam jede menge
vorschläge und erklärungsmöglichkeiten
ein nutzer schlug vor dass es sich um
eine versteinerte kreatur wie godzilla
handeln könnte oder aber könnten es
korallen sein die sich nach der
ablagerung von kalk gebildet haben ein
ehemaliges korallenriff also
möglicherweise ein anderer user warnte
nur dass sich etwas in der formation
befinden könnte die diskussionen auf
twitter liefen heiß und dann plötzlich
schalteten sich auch
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ein und tatsächlich finden sie auch für
diese kuriose stammformation eine
mögliche erklärung klar ist jedenfalls
das war nicht das erste mal dass solche
kuriosen funde auf dem mars gemacht
worden vor zwei jahren beispielsweise
hatten vor allem die star trek fans
gestaunt mitten in der heller steve
ebene dem größten einschlagkrater des
mars hat die nasa sonde mars
reconnaissance orbiter
eine wirklich kuriose aufnahme gemacht
das bild einer erhebung die wirklich
täuschend echt an das bekannte logo von
star trek erinnert die nasa hat
twitterte damals zu ihrer entdeckung auf
deutsch übersetzt so viel wie
aufmerksame beobachter könnten bemerken
dass das hier aussieht wie ein bekanntes
logo inmitten der sanddünen des mars
also eine wirklich kuriose entdeckung
fachleute hatten sich dann intensiv
damit beschäftigt und hatten später dann
klargestellt dass die ähnlichkeit zu dem
star trek logo wohl purer zufall ist auf
ihrer webseite erklärte die nasa die
entstehung dieser sogenannten share from
form die die experten auch als bühnen ab
küste bezeichnen demnach sind sie das
ergebnis eines komplexen zusammenspiels
von wind lava und dünen alles begann mit
einer sichelförmigen bühne die sich zu
einer insel im lava mehr entwickelte
diese sicht der förmigen dünen werden in
der fachsprache auch als dünn bezeichnet
auf dem mars machen sie ein großteil der
jugend aus irgendwann erstarrte die lava
und die dünnen raten weiterhin aus er
hervor durch den wind wurde der sand
weggeweht und diese fußspuren verblieben
in der lava ebene und es gab weitere
spektakuläre aufnahme von high rise
diese abkürzung steht für high
resolution imaging science experiment
eine hochauflösende kamera die sich an
bord der sonde mars reconnaissance
orbiter befindet beispielsweise von
pacman oder aber mappe bieker auch games
of thrones war schon auf dem roten
planeten ja zu gast zumindest erinnert
eine aufnahme einer staubspur auf dem
mars stark an das und ihr von houses tag
dieses muster entstand wohl durch eine
staub lawine die sich durch ein objekt
ein schlag gelöst hatte der staub hat so
diese dunkle sandschicht freigelegt
immer wieder kursierte ein bild durchs
netz das kuriose team bereits im august
vor sieben jahren 2014 gemacht hatte ein
beweis für leben auf dem roten planeten
wie es
verschwörungstheoretiker rinn immer
wieder betont angeblich ein
versteinerter menschlicher knochen ein
beweis also dafür dass der mars einst
leben beherbergte ein irrtum wie die
nasa feststellt auch hier kann alles auf
erosion zurückgeführt werden die nasa
stellt außerdem klar wenn es auf dem
mars jemals leben gegeben hätte erwarten
wissenschaftler dass es sich um kleine
einfache lebensformen handelt mikroben
also damals hatte wahrscheinlich nie
genug sauerstoff in seiner atmosphäre
und anderswo um komplexe organismen zu
ernähren daher sind große fossilien
unwahrscheinlich doch was sagt die
wissenschaft zum neuesten bild von
commodity der geheimnisvollen stein
formation aus dem sommer zunächst einmal
stellen die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler klar dass dieses bauwerk
ziemlich klein ist im durchmesser misst
der stein bogen gerade einmal wenige
zentimeter zudem sieht die
forschungsgemeinde den bogen nicht als
beweis für außerirdisches leben auf dem
mars denn auch auf der erde formen sich
solche böden ganz natürlich der mars
experte schreibt dazu auf twitter dass
diese formation für manche wie eine
schlange horn oder an dna strang geformt
sei er vermutet dass sich dieses
seltsame bauwerk wohl durch erosion
gebildet hat schon wieder also eine
enttäuschung für die die gehofft hatten
durch diese aufnahme endlich
außerirdisches leben auf dem mars
dingfest zu machen doch wie die nasa
schon sagt die suche konzentriert sich
stark auf mikroben denn dem hass
umgebung ist und war wohl nie für ein
komplexes leben geeignet viele fachleute
sind sich dennoch sicher dass wir bei
unserer suche nach außerirdischem leben
kurz vor einem durchbruch stehen ein
indiz für leben auf dem mars methan wie
es hier auf der erde von lebewesen
produziert wird und genau das wurde
jetzt aufgespürt leben auf dem mars
methanquelle direkt neben mars rover
rosetti anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren den abo button gibt es ja
unter jedem video macht schlau und
kostet nichts und natürlich dieses video
hier anschauen also bis dann bleibt dran